so you are someone who is on top of the
data
unlike just about anyone else what did
you get out of the latest report or
really any of the your recent findings
yeah I mean so I mean I've heard of this
key piece which I know you track really
closely to which is the willingness to
vote for uh a third party or a different
party than a democrat or republican
candidate and and that number has kind
of continued to grow I mean we have a
majority of likely voters who are at
least somewhat willing to to vote for a
third party candidate if they say so
um which is you know obviously an
important number to track
um I think the other thing that was
really critical and the research that we
did pre-election 2020 in post-election
is that there's kind of this
conventional wisdom among politicals
politicos and even among researchers
that democracy is just not an issue that
voters really care about at all you know
they could care about kitchen
quote-unquote kitchen table issues and
and democracy just doesn't matter
um and what we found that that that's
actually changing so yeah it was not the
number one issue
um you know by by any means the number
one issue for voters tended to be
inflation across the board
um you know Republicans some of them
it's immigration and safety and for
Democrats abortion was a big one this
year but democracy was ranking and
protecting elections in particular was
ranked right up there three or four
particularly in Battleground States
um where voters really understand kind
of the way that the system of democracy
the strength of our democracy truly does
matter uh and I thought that was one of
the the more interesting things that
really kind of cuts against this idea
that democracy doesn't matter and in
fact among voters that there weren't for
you know at that point there weren't
forward party options um but there were
an expanded number of we call shifters
or split ticket voters
um who would vote for you know a
Democrat for for one Statewide office
and a republican for another Statewide
office there were more of those in
Battleground States this year and for
those voters in particular protecting
elections Fair elections
um ranked higher
um you know than kind of your mean voter
which really indicates that for them it
it may have been a voting issue even if
it's not the issue that it's not the
same as making sure they have enough
money in their pocket it's it's pretty
close
um so those are some of the things I
think the other thing that we do a lot
of work on
and we tracked in this recent report is
just the the uh energy behind reforming
the primary system and giving voters you
know more options yeah most voters want
it they voted yeah it's really popular I
mean the only thing that's more popular
you know than that when in kind of the
realm of Reform is just money and
politics I mean voters who do that as
really the biggest problem
um and that's the harder one it's and
you know I've you know been on panels
about that
um there's things you can do but it's
it's a harder not to crack but democracy
reform really has a lot of momentum and
in each individual state that we've
looked at it as well across the country
uh both Republicans and Democrats uh
really want it they want it they want
better representation better options
more voice more Choice yeah almost 60
percent of Americans want to get rid of
uh party primaries so that's a great
sign for let's say Nevada uh next year
and what percentage of Americans say
they're at least open to voting uh for a
third party 60 percent
about the same sixty percent uh you know
obviously
um that's a lot higher than you need in
theory you don't even need 51 you know
you might need 35
um I'd actually tell people the real
number uh of what you would need to get
on board something like the forward
party in Earnest is only really more
like 10 because in a polarized country
you could swing a lot of races and do a
lot of good with that kind of Base yeah
that's right and you know
um I think the thing to look at too is
younger voters so the trends um younger
voters hate the parties yeah so younger
voters are most likely to identify as
independent be most dissatisfied with
the two-party system the most supportive
of a reform
um even you know youngest the youngest
Republicans
um there's a like a major Delta between
support for democracy reform among
younger Republicans and older
Republicans
um which I think is a really strong you
know Omen and gives us a really good
foundation to build on for the future
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you